[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
الجوانبه
روسيا تتهم الغرب بشن حرب غير معلنه عليها
وتباشر نقل اسلحه نوويه لبيلاروسيا
بعد تحضيره من ثوره وخساره الصراع
باوكرانيا قائد فاجنر يقترح تطبيق النموذج
الكوري الشمالي بروسيا
قبيل ايام من جوله الاعاده خشيه كرديه من
فوزي اردوغان وسط تصاعد النبره القوميه
بتركيا
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
الصين تتهم الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
بالتضليل وتنفي شن هجمات سيبرانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر
لوكاشينكو انه تم بالفعل البدء بنقل اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه من روسيا الى بيلاروسيا
واكد لوكاشينكو في تصريحات لوسائل اعلام
روسيه ان الاسلحه النوويه ستكون امنه
تماما وبعيده عن ايدي المخربين بما في ذلك
بولندا وفق قوله من جانبه اعتبر الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان قرار بيلاروسيا نشر اسلحه
نوويه روسيه في اراضيها يضاعف التوتر
ويؤكد ضلوع مسك في حرب اوكرانيا
هذا ووقع وزير دفاع روسيا وبلاروسيا اليوم
اذا وثيقه تحدد اجراءات نشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه روسيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا وزير
الدفاع الروسي سرقه اعتبر ان الغرب يصون
حربا غير معلنه على دولتين واكد ان قرار
الرد في المجال النووي ياتي وسط تصعيد
كبير للتهديدات على الحدود الغربيه لروسيا
[تصفيق]
جمهوريه بيلاروسيا كانت ولا تزال حليفا
حقيقيا وشريكا موثوقا به واليوم نقف معا
ضد الغرب الذي يقود بشكل جماعي حربا غير
معلنه ضد بلدينا
اذا البلدان الحليفان اتفقا على نشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا اضافه
لاسلحه ومقاتلات روسيا نعود للوراء قليلا
ففي السادس والعشرين من مارس اعلن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الناموسكو ستنشر
هذه الاسلحه النوويه في بيلاروسيا وقال ان
النشر لا ينتهك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه وما عدم توفر احصاءات رسميه قدرت
المخابرات الامريكيه ان روسيا تمتلك ما
يقرب من الفي سلاح نووي تكتيكي هذه
الاسلحه عباره عن رؤوس حربيه نوويه صغيره
مخصصه للاستخدام في ساحه المعركه لتدمير
اهداف العدو في منطقه معينه دون احداث
تداعيات تداعيات مثل اشعاع واسع النطاق
روسيا لم تكتفي فقط بنشر الاسلحه بل ارسلت
وسائل اطلاقها نتحدث هنا عن تجهي
المقاتلات سوخوي 25 لحمله معدات نوويه بعد
التدريب الطيارين البيلاروسيين عليها ايضا
اتفقت موسكو ومسك على نشر منظومات اس 400
وصواريخ اسكندر ام التي يمكن استخدامها
للصواريخ التقليديه والنوويه طبعا صاروخ
اسكندر ام تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت وبامكانه
الوصول لارتفاع 50 كيلومترا وبماذا يصل
الى 500 كيلومتر وتقل روسيا ان صواريخ
اسكندر قادره على المناوره وتجنب الصواريخ
المضاده للصواريخ الباليستيه وايضا تدمير
مختلف الاهداف الثابته اضافه للاسلحه التي
تم نشرها تعمل روسيا وبيلاروسيا على زياده
الاستعداد القتالي
للجيشين كما سيتم نشر وحدات عسكريه اضافيه
وتشير روسيا وحليفتها بيلاروسيا الى
التحركات الاخيره لا تخالف اي التزامات
دوليه وانها رد على ما اسمته بالنشاط
العسكري العدواني ينضم الينا حول هذا
الموضوع من برلين مصطفى العمار الخبير في
الامن الدولي اهلا بك سيد مصطفى يعني
بوتين يبرر هذا القرار بنيه لندن ارسال
ذخائر باليورانيوم المنظم لاوكرانيا خطوره
هذه الخطوه بدايه
وهل فعلا تمثل تهديدا للغرب
[موسيقى]
من التسعينات
الى روسيا اصبحت الان فعلا يعني متدخله
بهذه الحرب بشكل جدا يعني
واضح ورب ايضا ليس فقط هنا ايضا تجديد
العقوبات على بيلاروسيا وانما روسيا على
بيلاروسيا ايضا عليها ان لا تسير خلف
روسيا بهذا بهذا الاتجاه لان هذا فعلا سوف
يكون هناك تصعيد وان هذا التصعيد كارثي
جدا على ليس فقط على المنطقه باكملها
الرؤوس النوويه او الاسلحه النوويه هذا
ليس بلعبه سهله
وروسيا نراها هنا الان لا تريد او لا تريد
ان تاتي الى طاوله الحوار لنهايه لهذا
الحرب بعد بعد ولكن ايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سيد مصطفى تنشر اسلحه نوويه
بالمانيا وببلجيكا وايضا بايطاليا
يعني لماذا تنتقد ما تفعله روسيا
ولا ننتقد ما تفعله لندن والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما هو يعني تصعيد من
الطرفين اقصد
نقطه النووي
منذ عام 1949 كانت هناك المعاهدات خصوصا
وغيرها والعديد من المعادات وغيرها من
الذي حصلت هي اكدت على ان يكون هناك قياده
عن طريق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا
تتحد الامريكيه هي التي تقود ان حلف النات
حلف شمال الاطلس اصبح اكثر من الثلاثين
عضو واعتقد ان هناك مصالح مشتركه وقواعد
عسكريه عندما تقولين على سبيل
هذا كله هناك قواعد عسكريه ليس فقط روايات
المتحده الامريكيه لكن نعود
الى كيف يحصل هذا
هناك
يكون مفاوضات لحل هذه الازمه خصوصا اليوم
ايضا المانيا ايضا على الصين بان يكون
ايضا لاعب رئيسي يخص انه نحن في الايام
السابقه لم نسمع بان المانيا بان تكون
فعلا لاعب رئيسي في حل هذه الازمه انا
اتكلم هنا ايضا
يخصنا نتكلم هنا باسم السياسه الالمانيه
سيد مصطفى اذا كان الهدف الروسي يعني وضع
قواعد رعب جديده توازن رعب نووي اذا صح
التعبير ماذا ان حصل خطا بهذه الرؤوس
النوويه
اعتقد على روسيا ايضا ان تكون يعني تعرف
حجم هذه الكوارث منذ تقريبا ما حصل فيه
روشيما في الايام السابقه في الزمانات في
45 اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والعديد من الدول الصرف بان يكون هناك
فعلا المعاهدات لا تكون هناك
حروب نوويه صحيح صحيح هناك خلافات ونزاعات
لكن هذه كنا نود ونعمل ان تكون يتم حلها
دبلوماسيا راح نعول على الكثير من الاطراف
ان يكون لها ايضا النزاع حتى حتى عندما
ايضا شاركه في قمه في القمه العربيه وايضا
يعني
واضحه بانه فعلا يريد نهائي لهذا الحرب
لكن هذا الحرب ليس على حساب الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا هذا
او اين يقف القانون الدولي ان كان من خطوه
وقرار روسيا او قرار لندن بتزويد اوكرانيا
بذخائر اليورانيوم المنظم
انا اعتقد انه انه بريطانيا ليس فقط هي
بريطانيا الجميع الان هو يزود اوكرانيا
حتى وصلت الان تقريبا
اعطاها الى اوكرانيا بعد بعد زياره السيد
الى برلين ولا اعتقد ان هناك خرق للقوانين
الدوليه بما يعملوا الاتحاد الاوروبي
القوات شمال الاطلسي الخرق القوانين هو
التي بدات روسيا وهو هذا اعتقد اكبر يعني
شكرا جزيلا لك
خبير والام
ن
الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتلاتها اعترضت
محاوله قاذفتين استراتيجيتين امريكيتين
اختراق المجال الجوي الروسي فوق بحر
البلطيق اكدت الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتلاتها
نفذت طلعاتها بما يتفق بدقه مع القواعد
الدوليه لاستخدام المجال الجويه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي استون ان تدريب
الطيارين الاوكران على طائرات اف 16 سيبدا
الاسبوع المقبل وخلال كلمه له في اجتماع
لمجموعه الاتصال الدفاعيه الخاصه
باوكرانيا اكد اوستن انه يتم امداد
اوكرانيا بكافه الذخائر الضروريه
لمساعدتها في الهجوم المضاده
مجموعه العمل المشتركه تتاكد ان الجنود
الاوكرانيين يتلقون التدريبات اللازمه
نواصل العمل على تدريب جماعي للوحدات
الاوكرانيه في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر وصلت
31 دبابه من طراز الى المانيا وفي الاسبوع
الماضي اعلن الرئيس بايدن ان الولايات
المتحده والحلفاء ملتزمون بتدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على الطائرات من الجيل الرابع
بما في ذلك مقاتله اف 16 هذه التدريبات
ستبدا الاسبوع المقبل وذلك من شانه ان
يعزز قدرات القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه على
المدى الطويل
اعلنت مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه عن عمليه
التبادل للاسره مع القوات الاوكرانيه
ونشرت صورا لاسرع اوكرانيين وظهر قائد
مجموعه فاجنر وهو يخاطب الاسرى
الاوكرانيين ووعدهم بارسالهم الى منازلهم
كما اعلن بيجوجين اعاده جثتين لامريكي
وتركي قتل في معارك بخمه
لا تزال مقابله مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر يفقيني
بيجوجين مع احدى وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
تثير الجدله فبعد تحذيره من ثوره في روسيا
كتلك التي حدثت في عام 1917
وخساره الصراع باوكرانيا اعتبر بريكوجين
ان على روسيا الاستعداد لحرب طويله وفرض
موجات جديده من التعبئه اضافه لاغلاق
الحدود كما هي الحال في كوريا الشماليه
يجب على روسيا ان تعيش كالنموذج الكوري
الشمالي لعده سنوات وان تغلق جميع الحدود
وان تكف عن ان تكون عاطفيه والاهم من ذلك
الا يقيم سيرجي لابروف حفلات زفاف مع
الاصدقاء لا ادري ربما هذه انباء زائفه
لكن يجب جلب الجميع من الخارج والعمل بجد
حينها فقط سنصل الى بعض النتائج
اكد وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه دي متروكولي
بمواصله بلاده السعي لتجنب ازمات الغذاء
وضمان التعاون مع البلدان الاخرى حتى تصل
الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى افريقيا
روسيا هاجمت اوكرانيا ومع ذلك فاننا نواصل
بدل كل ما في وسعنا لضمان تطوير التعاون
التجاره مع البلدان الاخرى حتى تصل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه الى افريقيا لتجنب ازمات
الغذاء والمجاعه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
نقص الادويه واستهداف المنشات الطبيه
اشتباكات السودان تزيد معاناه الالاف من
المصابين بالامراض المزمنه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت الاحزاب والمواليه
للاكراد في تركيا دعما مرشح الرئاسه
المعارض
في جوله الاعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
دون تسميته وقال مسؤولون من حزب الشعب
الديمقراطي وحلفائهم من حزب اليسار الاخضر
انهم يسعون الى التغيير في جوله الاعاده
ولا يقبلون ببقايا اردوغان مشيرين الى
انهما سيصوتان لصالح انهاء نظام الرجل
الواحد
الى ذلك قالت وكاله رويترز ان الاكراد
المعارضين للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يخشون من ان فوزه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
قد يعزز القمعه ضدهم وينظر الى الاكراد
الذين يشكلون نحو خمس سكان تركيا على انهم
ربما يكونوا عنصر الحسم بالنسبه للمعارضه
التي تامل بانهاء حكم اردوغان وبالنسبه
لبعض الناخبين الاكراد فهم لن يواجهوا
مخاطر اكبر مع تشديد اردوغان نبرته
القوميه في محاوله لكسب اصوات المزيد من
الناخبين قبل جوله الاعاده الاحد المقبل
وفاز حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي بنسبه 61% في
ديار بكر في الانتخابات البرلمانيه منتصف
الشهر الجاري الا انه حصل على
8.9% في عمومي ارجاء تركيا
وينضم الينا من اسطنبول الدكتور سمير
صالحه الاستاذ في العلاقات الدولي اهلا بك
معنا سيد سمير يعني حظوظ كمال كليتش دار
اوغلو بعد اعلان الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد
اليوم دعمها له في جوله الاعاده
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا طبعا يعني
موقف حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه مهم رغم انه
لما يذكر بالاسم كمال قال انه لن يدعم
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وهذا يعني يصب
مباشره لصالح كمال لكن في مشكله اساسيه
انه هل قواعد هذا الحزب ستلتزم بقرار
السلطه السياسيه او الاداره السياسيه
وتذهب يوم الاحد المقبل الى صناديق
الاقتراع ام لا هذه هي براي النقطه
الاساسيه لماذا لانه كما تعرفون كمال في
اليومين الاخيرين بدا ينصق مع احد
الشخصيات السياسيه المحسوبه على اليمين
القومي
صح هذا الذي كنت اسالك عنه مخاوف الاكراد
وماذا ان صدقت الانباء التي تتحدث بانه
كمال كليتش دور اوغلو وعدا اوميت اوسداق
بحقيبه الداخليه في حال نجاحه بالوصول الى
الرئاسه ماذا سيحصل حينها ومعروف هذا
الرجل بانه خطابه متطرف ضد اللاجئين وضد
الاكراد
صحيح تقديم وزاره الداخليه
لرئيس حزب ظفر في حال فوز
يشكل
ازمه مهمه في داخل التركي على مستوى
القيادات السياسيه والاحزاب حتى داخل
الطاوله السداسيه التي تدعم كمال برايس
يكون هناك نقاشات مطوله في حال الاقدام
كمال القرش على خطوه من هذا النوع كان في
نفي من قبل رئيس حزب ظفر ومن قبل ان يكون
هناك تفاهمات حول تسليم هذا المنصب لماذا
لانه قيل انه ينبغي اولا التريث نتائج
الانتخابات وبعد ذلك يتم عمليه النقاش حول
اي مناصب وكيف تتم عمليه توزيع هذه
المناصب لكن في جميع الاحوال حتى وجود
رئيس حزب ظفر الى جانب كمال الكرشتار
اوغلو هنا برايي احتمال انه قد يكون له
ارت سلبيه كما قلت لك في صفوف
داعمي حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي وربما حتى في
صفوف الاحزاب الدائمه لكم مثل حزب اياد
كمان
اخرى مهمه كمان نعرف جميعا هي انه لم ينجح
في اقناع رئيس حزب البلد محرم ان جاء
بالوقوف الى جانبه اذا يحتاج ربما الى
معجزه كمال قولوا بالمقارنه بين اصوات
الجوله الاولى بينه وبين الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان يعني يحتاج الى على الاقل الى سته
ملايين او سبعه ملايين صوت ليثبت هذا
الفوز في الجوله الثانيه الدكتور سمير
يعني بين اول جوله وجوله الاعاده برايك ما
الذي تغير او سيتغير ولمست بنبض الشارع
التركي هل تتوقع مفاجات لانه حتى خطاب
المرشحين
تغير اصبح اكثر قوميه
تماما اتفق معك النقطه الاولى الاساسيه هي
بعد النتائج الانتخابات في الجوله الاولى
صعود
وبروز الصوت القومي اليمين القومي في
تركيا الان كسب شعبيه جديده اضافيه حوالي
20 25% من مجموع الاصوات بعد
الانتخابات يوم الاثنين سنعرف اذا كانت
هذه الكتله
تواصل صعودها ام لا على ضوء الارقام
وسنعرف اكثر اذا مكان ستذهب باتجاه
التلاحم فيما بينها واحتمال ان تتحول الى
لاعب اساسي في مساله التوازنات السياسيه
والحزبيه في الداخل التركي نقطه ثانيه
باختصار لن اطيل في الجوله الاولى كما
تتذكرين الحملات الانتخابيه كانت تذهب
باتجاه التركيز على ملفات الاقتصاد ملفات
الاوضاع المعيشيه وغير ذلك لكن في الجوله
الثانيه يبدو ان المعارضه نجحت في الدفع
الامور نحو الملف الذي تريده هي ملف
اللجوء تحديدا اللاجئ السوري في تركيا
دكتور سمير انا انتهى وقتي ولكن باختصار
لو سمحت هل ترى مستقبلا لهذه المعارضه في
حال خسرت هذه الانتخابات
هذه المعارضه برايي خسرت حتى ولو لم تذهب
الى الصناديق في الجوله الثانيه معارضه
مشرده مفككه ربما الذي الان يقف الى جانبا
يحاول ان يوفر لها فرصه لصعود هو رئيس حزب
ظفر لكن صباح الاثنين انا وانت سنرصد عن
قرب في حال فشل كما الكريستال اوهلو اجواء
سياسيه وحزبيه جديده على مستوى المعارضه
التركيه شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور سمير صالحه
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه بان اليه
مراقبه اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
رصدت عده انتهاكات للاتفاق بما في ذلك
استخدام المدفعيه والطائرات الحربيه
والمسيارات من جهاته قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ماثيو ميلر في بيان ان
بلاده تواصل الاتصال مع طرفي الصراع مشيرا
الى ان واشنطن ستستخدم جميع الادوات
الممكنه لتحميل الطرفين مسؤوليه الصراع
الحالي الذي يشهده البلاد
يواجه الالاف من مصابي الامراض المزمنه
على راسها الاورام السرطانيه صعوبه في
الحصول على جرعات العلاج المقرره لهم فبعد
خروج نسبه كبيره من المراكز والمستشفيات
العلاجيه في الخرطوم بسبب الحرب توجه كثير
من المرضى نحو شرق السودان لاستكمال
علاجهم غير ان المراكز العلاجيه في مدينه
بورسودان تمر ايضا بمشكلات على راسها ان
نقص الحاد في بعض ادويه السرطان
لاشهر وعرف تداوم على اخذ جرعاتها
الدوائيه بمركز علاج الاورام السرطانيه
بمدينه بورسودان في ظروف الحرب تمثل جرعه
الدواء هذه نافذه امل لعرفه
من على بعد تطمئن الاهل بحصولها على
جرعتها العلاجيه لكنها تتخوف من تضاؤل فرص
علاجها وندره الدواء بسبب تداعيات الحرب
يعني نقص لحد ما يجيني من البرد ظروف
الحرب منه كان بيجي بالخرطوم
انقطع مننا
يكتظ مركز الاورام السرطانيه بطالب العلاج
استقبل المركز خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
2700 مريض نسبه كبيره منهم وصلت من عاصمه
البلاد الضغط على المركز يفوق طاقته
الاستيعابيه وفوق كل هذا يحذر مسؤولون من
تبعات وخطوره نفاذ بعض الادويه المهمه
داخل المركز حوالي 3 اسابيع نحن فتحنا
67 ملف المريض من خارج الولايه
يستخدموا نفس حصه الدواء اللي كان بتيجي
لمريض الولايه حاليا في ادويه بدات يعني
تنفذ الكميه بتاعتها تدريجيا حسب
استهلاكها العلاج الهرموني
وقف تماما جزء من العلاج الكيميائي وقف
برضه جزء من الادويه الموجهه
انهيار جزء كبير من البنى التحتيه للقطاع
الصحي في الخرطوم جعل المستشفيات في
بورسودان امام تحديات توفير العلاج لمئات
المرضى القادمين من العاصمه كما يفرض هذا
الواقع مسؤوليه اخرى على السلطات الرسميه
لتامين الدواء
ولمعالجه الموقف بدء التحرك لتوفير ما
يلزم من ادويه لمقابله الاحتياجات الصحيه
الملحه نحو الف طن من المساعدات الانسانيه
وصلت بورسودان خلال الايام الماضيه غير ان
الموقف الدوائي يستدعي تحركا لضمان وصول
الادويه للمراكز العلاجيه بصوره عاجله
دفعنا الحاويه بتاعتنا لكل الدول الشارقه
من الامراض المزمنه خاصه في غسيل الكلى
والاورام وحتى في امراض السكري والضغط
الانسولين وكده ما شابه وده بياتي اتباعا
زي ما انا قلت فيه زي 952 طن وهنا برضو من
امراض الطبيه اللجنه بتعمل صباحا ومساء في
توزيع الامداد الدوائي لكل الولايات ومع
استمرار الاشتباكات المسلحه وموجات النزوح
فان الوضع الصحي يواجه مخاطر حقيقيه وهي
مخاطر قد تهدد حياه الاف المرضى في البلاد
نزار البغداوي العربيه بورت سودان
اكد الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم ببداوي حرصا المجلس على دعمه استعاده
الامن والسلامه والاستقرار في اليمن وشدد
البداوي خلال لقائه وزير الخارجيه اليمني
احمد عوض بن مبارك على الموقف الثابت
لمجلس التعاون الخليجي بشان دعم جهود
انهاء الازمه اليمنيه من خلال الحل
السياسي والحفاظ على وحده اليمن وسيادته
من جهته اشد وزير الخارجيه اليمني بدوري
دول الخليج خاصه مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
لتنفيذ مشروعات تنمويه لتوفير الحياه
الكريمه لليمنيين
[موسيقى]
لن يكون الحلف هيكلا كاملا دوننا تابعونا
بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعتقلت الشرطه رجلا بعد
اصطدام سياره بوابات مقر رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني بوسط لندن اقلت الشرطه في بيان
انه قرابه الساعه الثالثه وعشرون دقيقه
بتوقيت جرينتش اصطدمت سياره ببوابات داون
وقام افراد من الشرطه باعتقالي رجل في
مكان الحادث تحت شبهه اضرار جرميه وقياده
متهوره
[موسيقى]
دانت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه اختبار
ايران لصاروخ باليسي بعيد المدى معتبره
انه انتهاك لقرارات مجلس الامن ومدعات
للقلق في ضوء التوسع المتواصل للبرنامج
النووي الايراني ياتي هذا بعد اعلان
الجانب الايراني اجراء التجارب اطلاق
صاروخ بالستي بنجاح
الى ذلك دعى النائب الالماني عن حزب
الاتحاد المسيحي الديمقراطيه المعارض
رودريش كيفستر حكومه بلاده الى ممارسه
ضغوط اضافيه على ايران مؤكدا ان طهران
باتت على مسافه قصيره من تخصيب اليورانيوم
بدرجه تسمح لها بالحصول على سلاح النووي
انا قلق للغايه من الطريق الذي تسلكه
ايران ان شخصيا ممنوع من دخول ايران بقرار
اصدرته السلطات هناك لانني وجهت انتقادات
للتصرفات في وجه المحتجين نصف الشعب
الايراني تحت الضغط اتحدث عن النساء هناك
عشره الاف امراه في السجون والمئات قتلنا
وفتيات المدارس تعرضنا للتسمم النساء لا
حريه لهن في ايران ومن جهه اخرى نرى ان
ايران لا تقبل بحق اسرائيل في الوجود وهي
تعمل على تطوير قنبله نوويه وهذا امر مثير
للقلق بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
اتهمت متحدثه باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بشن حمله تضليل بعدما قالت
واشنطن وشركائها الغربيين ومايكروسوفت ان
جهف فاعله سيبرانيه مدعومه من بكين تسللت
الى شبكات امريكيه للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه
اطلعنا على التقرير واود ان اقول انه
تقرير عدلناه معا مع نقص خطير في الادله
وعدم المهنيه ولا توجد احترافيه كما
لاحظنا ان هناك تقارير مماثله صدرت في وقت
واحد من قبل الوكالات الحكوميه كوكاله
الامن القومي الامريكيه واخرى ذات صله في
المملكه المتحده واستراليا وكندا
ونيوزيلندا وغيرها من الدول من الواضح
انها حمله تظليل جماعيه من قبل الولايات
المتحده لتعبئه البلدان في تحالف العيون
الخمس لاغراض جيوسياسيه
اذا تلجا الصين لمحاوله اختراق شبكات
البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه بحسب شركه
مايكروسوفت عملاق التقنيه الامريكيه اعلن
رصد نشاط سيبراني تنفذه مجموعه صينيه هذه
المجموعه تدعى
التي قالت مايكروسوفت انها تحظى برعايه
رسميه من السلطات الصينيه كما حضرت
مايكروسوفت من ان الهجوم يهدد باحداث
اضطرابات في البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
للاتصالات بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسيا في المستقبل واوضحت مايكروسوفت
اربعه تكتيكات تستخدمها فولتايفون لمهاجمه
مؤسسات تعمل في قطاعات الاتصالات والصناعه
وايضا التعليم التكتيك الاول يعتمد على
جمع البيانات بما في ذلك بيانات الانظمه
المحليه والشبكات المرتبطه بها ليتم بعد
ذلك في المرحله الثانيه وضع هذه البيانات
في ملفات ارشيفيه متسلسله التكتيك
تعمد او تعمد المجموعه الصينيه الى
استخدام البيانات المسروقه وافساح المجال
لامكانيه الوصول اليها اخيرا تقوم فولت
تايفون بدمج انظمتها ضمن نطاق عمل الشبكات
في المؤسسات التي تم اختراقها وتوجيه حركه
مرور البيانات عبر الشبكه صينيه لتسهيل
الدخول اليها وقت الحاجه بدورها قالت
وكاله الامن القومي الامريكي ان المجموعه
الصينيه تستخدم ادوات مدمجه في الشبكات
للتهرب من رصدها وعدم ترك اي اثر خلفها ما
يصعب امر اكتشاف هذه التقنيات كما وضعت
الوكاله ارشادات فنيه للشركات التي تعمل
في قطاع البنيه التحتيه لتحديد النشاطات
الخبيثه او الضاره واحتمال وجود اختراقات
من قبل فولت ايفون ينضم الينا من بكين
الصحفي نادي الرونج ومن واشنطن ايضا
الدكتور
عقيل عباس الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه
الامريكيه اهلا بكما
ابدا معك سيد نادر
كيف تنظر بكين الى هذه الاتهامات رغم انها
تعتبرها حمل التضليل من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وايضا حلفائها ولكن
هذه المجموعه يقال بانها مرتبطه ومدعومه
من الحكومه الصينيه
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذه
الالتحامات يعني ليس تنكوسها
سلسله
الادله
وكذلك ليس يعني لها اساس من الصحه وهي
من هي مبرمجه من قبل هذه الدول الخمسه
يعني لاحداث لتحقيق احد اهداف الجيول
السياسيه وكذلك
الدول
الناس يعني من
الاعمال الامريكيه للتجسس من من الولايات
المتحده الى الصين
فلذلك
تعرفوا هذه الاتهامات
وتريد ان تؤكد ان الصين هي هي المتضرره
من مثل هذه يعني هجوم السيبراني وان
الولايات المتحده
سيد نادر يعني هي ضحيه بماذا
مثلا
السن كانت تتعرض كذلك
يعني هجوم السيبراني من قبل الولايات
المتحده بشكل مستمر
كما اصدرت الصين في
العام الماضي هناك جامعه صينيه لصناعه
بشمال يعني غربي الصين
دائما تتعارض
الهجوم السيبراني من قبل الولايات المتحده
وكذلك هناك
مؤسسات
رائده صينيه وكذلك الاجهزه الحكوميه
والمستشفيات
الدكتور عقيل معنا بهذا النقاش هل يمكن
برايك الربط بين هذا النشاط
التجسسي الذي تتحدث عنه مايكروسوفت
والاستخبارات الامريكيه مع اسقاط المنطاد
الصيني التجسسي قبل اشهر والذي حلق فوق
الولايات الامريكيه
لانه هذه فرضيه فعليا تؤيدها صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز بتقرير لها
اشكرك على هذه الاستضافه يعني الفهم
الاميركي انه هذا العام شاهد تصاعدا يعني
غير مالوف بخصوص الانشطه التجسسيه الصينيه
خصوصا التجسس التكنولوجي والتجاري وانه
هذا المنطاد قصه هذا المنطاد هي علامه
البدايه على هذا التصاعد يعني مثلا الحديث
عن هذا
النشاط التجسسي الاخير اختراعكم منظومات
اتصالات يعني هناك اعتقاد واسع انها تريد
ان تؤثر على الرد الاميركي المحتمل على اي
هجوم صيني نحو تايوان ان هذا بدا في الشهر
الثاني يعني في وقت قريب من قصه المنطاد
وتواصل الى ان اكتشفه الاميركيون غرض هذا
النشاط كما يبدو هو فقط سرقه المعلومات
وتجريب الدخول على المنظومات الاميركيه
لاستخدام
هذه القدره مستقبلا ربما لقطع الاتصالات
في حاله نشوف نزاع للصين تاريخ طويل في
التجسس التكنولوجي والتجاري على يعني مثلا
قبل عامين نصف تحقيقات قضايا التجسس التي
كانت تجريها نصفها كانت تتعلق بالصين يعني
العالم كله نصف والصين نصف وهذه في ازدياد
جزء من الصعود الاقتصادي الصيني هو يقوم
على هذا التجسس سرقت معلومات بخصوص ابحاث
تقوم بها شركات وتحصل في النهايه هذه
الشركات على براءات اختراع ثم
بضائعها الصين تدخل على هذه المنظومات
وتسرق المعلومات عن هذا الاتهام الذي
يتكرر الذين وقفوا امام محاكم امريكيه
اعداد كبيره من الصينيين الذين اتهموا
باعمال كهذه فهذا النشاط هو حقيقه ليس
جديدا
ونشاط ما هو غير معتاد هو تصاعده المحموم
حسب مصادر امريكيه لهذا الان
يعني التصور الامريكي يعني هناك مجموعه
تصورات وانه هو جزء من تحضيرات صينيه او
اختبارات صينيه
ضربه او عمل عسكري بخصوص تايوان قدره
الولايات المتحده على الرد من خلال تعطيل
منظومات الاتصال يعني مثلا في الموانع سكك
الحديد
قواعد الامريكيه الموجوده في قوام جزيره
غوام القريبه نسبيا من الصين هذه هي
الافتراضات الامريكيه القائمه على الاطلاع
على الادله طبعا هذه الادله تكشف لكنه
الخلاصات منها يعني نشر بعضها السيد نادر
رايك بما ينقله ضيفنا الدكتور عقيل عن
فرضيات امريكيه بارتباط هذه
النشاطات التجسسيه وتصاعدها بضربه محتمله
على تايوان
يعني كما قلت يعني اكدت سين ان هذه لا
توجد اي يعني ادله مقنعه لتثبت ان هذه
يعني حجمات السيبرانيه
هي قامت بها الصين وكذلك
اكدت المراره من تكرار عن الولايات
المتحده هي اكبر دوله يعني في العالم تقوم
بالشان يعني هجمات السيبرانيه للدول
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
باستخدام
باستغلال التفوقها في التقنيات الاتصالات
ويمكن ان نرى في يعني اعوام الماضيه هناك
محاولات كثيره من جهاز الامن الاستخاره او
الجهاز الاستخبارات الامريكيه
لتحاول الاسقاط الحكومات الدول الاخرى من
خلال هذا
التقنيات وكذلك
تقوم بما يسمى
بالثوره ملونه وكذلك التجسس على حتى على
حلفائها يعني التجسس
الاستماع الى المعلومات قاعده الدول
الحنيفه وهذا يعني معروف
تعتبر يعني فضيحه المعروفه لدى الجميع
وكذلك يعني هذا يعتبر ايضا الهيمنه
للخدمات التكنولوجيه
وحتى الربيع العرب حسب معلومات الوارده
فهناك يعني
يعني
اتصال هناك السله بينها وبين الحجمات
السيبرانيه الامريكيه
سيد عقيل يعني الصين تنفي بشده
اتهامات للبيت
الطرف الاخر يفعل نفس الشيء يعني ما
النتيجه من هذا الجدل ومعروف بانه الهجمات
السيبرانيه قليل جدا
ولا يعرف من هو مصدرها
طبعا لا بد من التمييز بين نوعين من
الانشطه التجسس السياسي والامني وهذا يحدث
بين كل الدول لا يوجد قانون دولي ينظمه
هناك نقاش قانوني حقيقه بخصوص هذا دوله
تتجسس على دول اخرى الولايات المتحده
تجسست على حلفائها وهذا كان خطا كبيرا سبب
فضيحه
رؤساء امريكيون يعني حلفائهم في غيرها
اينها قيل يعني في وقت قصه سنودن حين عقيل
يعني رؤساء بعض المؤسسات الامريكيه تصرفوا
من دون استئذان او الحصول على الاذونات
القانونيه وقيل ايضا انه وضعت يعني قواعد
تنظم هذا هل سيحدث هذا من جديد الحدث اذا
حدث طبعا هذا يسبب احراج الولايات المتحده
هذا خطا الجانب الثاني
التجسس التكنولوجي والتجاري هذه قصه
مختلفه لا تتعلق بالامن والسياسه وانما
تتعلق بالسرقه سرقه التفاصيل اقتصاديه
ترتبط بشركات معينه لا الصين بهذا يعني
حتى هذه جزء من الخلاف الشديد بين الغرب
والصين عدم احترام الصين للحقوق الملكيه
الفكريه هذه الشركه حكم ملايين عشرات
الملايين من الدولارات في الابحاث من اجل
الوصول الى انتاج بضاعه ما ومن ثم تصديرها
الى السوق وتحفظ هذه الاسرار بموجب قوانين
دوليه ووطنيه الصين لا تسرق هذه المعلومات
يعني جهود الاخرين نتحدثون عن شركات
المتحده خارج يعني هذا موضوع نقاش اخر
يعني لكننا هنا نتحدث عن شيء محدد يعني
التي التي اخرجت الموضوع هي شركه
مايكروسوفت هذه شركه خاصه لا تمثل الحكومه
الامريكيه هذا بنفسه هو دليل على فداحه ما
قامت به الصين هنا بهذا الصدد يعني محاوله
اختراق شركات خاصه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك وضحت الفكره الدكتور
عقيل عباس وايضا الصحفيين نادي الروم
[موسيقى]
اكد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان الولايات
المتحده لن تتخلف عن سداد ديونها واوضح
بايضا انه اجرى عده محادثات مثمره مع رئيس
مجلس النواب كيفن
كانت لدي محادثات عده مثيره مع الرئيس
مجلس النواب كيفن قافي وطلبت منه استمرار
المباحثات التي تحرز تقدمها واؤكد ان
التخلف عن سداد الدين ليس خيارا مطروحا
فالشعب الامريكي يستحق ان يعلم ان مدفوعات
الخدمات الاجتماعيه ستستمر ان المستشفيات
ستظل مفتوحه وسنواصل التقدم الاقتصادي
الذي حققناه التخلف عن سداد الدين سيضع كل
هذا في خطر
يدركون كل ذلك وهم متفقون على انه لا يكون
هناك تخلف عن سداد الدين
انه يوم اخر من المفاوضات بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين والبيت الابيض مع بعض الامل
بالتوصل الى اتفاق يوم الخميس اطلب
الموافقه بالاجماع على انه بعد رفع الجلسه
ان يعود مجلس النواب الى الاجتماع غدا
كان هذا افضل مؤشرا على ان الاتفاق ممكن
حيث كان من المنتظر ان يغادر اعضاء
الكونغرس يوم الخميس في اجازه تذكار
الموتى على ان يعودوا له طلب منهم ذلك
وزاد من معدلات التفاؤل قول رئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن مكارثي انه تم تحقيق تقدم في
مفاوضات يوم الاربعاء في البيت الابيض
عملنا لما بعد منتصف الليل وكان يوما جيدا
وحققنا بعض التقدم وما زالت هناك بعض
المشاكل العالقه وطلبت من الطاقم متابعه
العمل على مدار الساعه
ليس من الواضح بعد ما هي تفاصيل الاتفاق
المحتمل وما هي المصروفات التي سيوافق
الديمقراطيون على اقتطاعها مقابل رفع سقف
الدين وهم حتى صباح الخميس ما زالوا
غاضبين ويتحدثون عن دعم المحاربين القدامى
وبرامج المساعدات
المحاربون القدامى يواجهون مشكله بسبب
الجمهوريين الذين اخترعوا مشكله سقف الدين
ومع هذه التناقضات بدات الاسواق تشعر اكثر
بالضغوطات وبدات تتسرب معلومات من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه عن انها ستدفع لاصحاب
السندات اولا لو لم يتوصل الطرفان الى
اتفاق
هناك خطط لدى جمعيات السندات والاسواق
لمتابعه العمل وتبادل السندات والتصرف
وكانه ليس هناك مشكله بدا الاطراف بتحقيق
تقدم ولكن وزاره الخزانه والاسواق تستعد
للسيناريو الاسوا والسيناريو الاسوا هو
عدم دفع الدوله للاجور والمعاشات عند ذلك
لا احد يعرف كيف تسير الاسواق في الغنم
العربيه واشنطن
واجهها حاكم فلوريدا بدايه متعثره مع
تدشين حملته للفوز بقياده الحزب الجمهوري
نحو سباق الرئاسه الامريكي وقد اختار
روندي سانتس منصه تويتر لاطلاق حملته
بصحبه الملياردير ماسك الا انه واجه
العديد من الاعطال الفنيه ليغتنم بذلك
خصمه بايدن من الحزب الديمقراطي والترامب
من الحزب الجمهوري الفرصه ويسخرني منه
بدايه متعثره للروندي سانتس الطامح في
هزيمه ترامب وقياده الحزب الجمهوري في
سباق الرئاسه الامريكيه العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
جين حملته فانهار الموقع وتعثر الاتصال
تشويش وسط وانقطاع متواصل في الاتصال برره
ايلون ماسك صاحب الموقع بالضغط الهائل على
الشبكه وكثره
من ذلك وعلق على منصته
مفتتحي الاحمر اكبر وافضل واقوى ويعمل
جيدا مفتاحك لا يعمل بايدن انتهز الفرصه
ايضا نشر رابطا لحملته وكتب هذا الموقع
يعمل
لقد صمدنا عندما تم تهديد الحريه اطهرنا
اننا نستطيع ويجب اعاده احياء امريكا نحن
بحاجه الى الشجاعه للقياده والقوه للفوز
انا راندي سانتوس اعلن ترشحي لانتخابات
الرئاسه لقياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى
ورغم البدايه المتعثره تقنيا
الا انه تمكن من جمع مليون دولار في ساعه
واحده لدعم حملته الانتخابيه ما يعني انه
لن يكون منافسا سهلا لا للترامب ولا لبعد
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم يجب على العالم الحر الفهم
بانه بدون اوكرانيا لن يكون الاتحاد
الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلسي هيكلين كاملين
ابدا هذه كانت كلمات رئيس البرلمان
الاوكراني رسلان ستيفان تشوك ويبدو ان
المسؤول الاوكراني كان يرد على تصريحات
الامين العام لحلف الناتو الذي اكد امس ان
انضمام كياف للحلف وسط الحرب ليس وارده
سوره اليوم من موسكو هو اعتزاز بالهويه
السويديه ام تاكيد على دعم اوكرانيا ربما
الامران معا فالوان العلمين متشابهين
وكانت لافته على مظلات
دبلوماسيين سويديين وهم يغادرون مبنى
سفاره بلادهم في العاصمه الروسيه الصوره
التقطت بعد اعلان موسكو طرده خمسه
دبلوماسيين سويديين ردا على خطوه مماثله
من ستوكل الاجراء ياتي في اطار موجه طرد
متبادله بين روسيا والغرب زادت وترتها منذ
بدء هجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
حبل ودلو وبعض الحظ هذا ما تحتاجه النساء
في احدى قرى نشيك شرق الهند الحصولي على
بعض من مياه الشرب غير النظيفه وللنجات
اثناء المحاوله يخاطرنا بحياتهن للنزول
الى بئر موحل لكنها وحيده بهدف الحصول على
بعض المياه ثم تبدا عمليات الترشيح
والتصفيه الحكومه وعدت بتوفير مياه صالحه
للشرب للقريه خلال الايام لكن حتى ذلك
الحين سيتعين عليهن المخاطره
اشكركم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه وننتقل
الى الزميل صهيب شراير واخبار الساعه
والمزيد من الملفات مساء الخير مساء الخير
راويه اهلا بك طبعا كالعاده الفتره
الاخباريه المسائيه نختمها مع اخبار
الساعه جوله سريعه شامله ومتنوعه خبر
الساعه تصريح بان اوكرانيا قد تختفي بعد
نهايه الحرب تفضل شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد
من قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات